salut Nowell, quel
rêve c'est tellement génial ce que vous
avez fait wow oh mon
Dieu pas étrange, juste
comme si vous m'avez définitivement fait des recherches,
vous me manquez, vous manquez oh non,
vous avez aussi ce livre mon Dieu
wow alors dites-moi où vous voulez  je peux y
aller je pourrais m'asseoir ici pour l'instant ok c'est
ok pour
toi j'aime
les chambres confortables donc euh je ne sais pas
je suis toujours dans la cuisine je suis toujours dedans il y a
un petit coup à côté de
la cuisine  Je suis toujours
là,
euh, je n'aime pas les immenses pièces pour m'asseoir seul
dans d'immenses pièces, tout seul, mais
euh, tu as même eu le poker
Haunter, c'est
incroyable, soi-
disant,
oui
ouais, je pourrais
déplacer
des super
modèles, c'est la première fois qu'on est  tous
ensemble, dans la
cinquantaine, vous voyez notre photo, donc vous sentez que
vous nous connaissez
lorsque vous vous réunissez avec la
famille que vous avez choisie. Je pense que c'est
émouvant, il y a quelque chose dans cette
histoire commune que
nous avons. Je me sens béni d'être ici aujourd'hui, nous avons tous  nous avons vécu tellement
de choses dans notre propre
Liv Cindy Linda Christy et Naomi sont
encore en train de redéfinir ce que signifie être
mannequin on avait le sentiment qu'elles en
voulaient plus Je n'étais pas considérée comme
une personne qui avait une voix dans son propre
destin il  J'ai dit que tu devrais perdre 5 livres. J'ai eu
peur, je n'étais pas à ma place mais Linda est un
caméléon, elle pourrait vraiment devenir
ce que le photographe voulait qu'elle
devienne. Je ferais tous ces grands spectacles, je
porterais toutes ces belles robes, mais
ensuite viendrait le temps de la publicité
et  Je ne serais pas inclus Je n'allais pas
être victime d'intimidation à cause de la couleur de ma
peau Ce que j'aimais chez les filles, c'était
un groupe et c'était tellement fabuleux que nous
étions toujours ensemble et nous faisions de superbes
photos ensemble, vous savez, j'avais juste l'
impression  être ensemble en groupe, c'était
tellement amusant, ce sont mes
sœurs, euh, je
soutiens définitivement euh ouais Christie et moi
étions très proches et euh nous étions colocataires
et j'ai rencontré Christie à Londres et donc oui
et je connaissais sa famille, elle connaissait ma famille
Je connaissais sa mère et ses sœurs, elle connaissait ma
mère, ma famille,
j'ai l'impression que si chaque fois que tu fais
quelque chose, tu sais que tu peux
voyager, Londres, New York, Milan, Paris, tu sais, donc c'est
définitivement un
soutien mutuel et un moral, tu
sais si  on se fatigue si l'un tombe malade
tu sais que tu es là pour booster l'autre
et le faire passer pour que tu saches que
c'était le cas et que c'était bien c'était aussi amusant
d'être ensemble dans le même
pays euh avec tous nos amis CU là-bas
Nous étions beaucoup plus nombreux
et c'était juste une époque, vous savez, nous
faisions les circuits de la Fashion Week et vous
savez, sautions d'un pays à un
hôtel, mais nous le faisions ensemble, donc
c'était amusant, c'était comme une ambiance de dortoir, euh,
ça  c'était le monde de Vogue que nous faisions et
c'était euh c'était amusant de faire ça ouais et
euh plus tôt dans la journée, Cindy et Christie
étaient venues me rendre visite pour rendre visite à mon fils donc
c'était bien, c'était bien de les avoir à
Londres tout ce que nous avions à faire
fais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
regarde
[Musique]
liberté liberté
libéré c'est euh c'était le
show de Johnny Versace
et euh donc j'étais dans le show donc
je pense qu'après ça c'était comme  on s'est précipité
hors de la scène et dans la tenue suivante
car cela faisait partie du spectacle euh le
segment mais Johnny était toujours très euh il
était toujours génial pour
nous célébrer et nous
nous invitions toujours à célébrer avec lui
aussi
donc euh c'était génial  faire
[de la musique],
je veux dire pour de vrai, je veux dire, en tant que femme de
couleur, ça n'a pas été aussi facile et
je ne m'attends pas à ce que quelque chose soit facile dans
la vie et ça m'a appris à valoriser chaque
tremplin,
euh, ça n'a jamais été ça  J'ai eu une
trace intérieure de cette industrie,
vous
savez, en fin de compte, mon instinct me disait ce que
j'aimerais faire et
celui qui m'offrait les
opportunités et se réunissait de
cette façon,
euh, je veux dire, que ce soit être un  mannequin ou
quel que soit le travail que vous choisissez, vous devez d'abord
aimer ce que vous faites et j'aime ce que je fais
et je suis reconnaissant pour les opportunités
que j'ai pu avoir et travailler
avec ces incroyables créatifs de la
fin des années 80 jusqu'à maintenant et  voir
toute l'industrie évoluer comme elle l'a fait, euh
c'était juste génial d'avoir cette
vue très proche de tout cela et de pouvoir toujours en faire
partie
[Musique]
Je vivais avec un menteur et euh donc là, un papa
vivait dans le mar  et
euh donc nous vivions dans le Maray donc j'ai vécu
avec lui
et dans euh et Rudy Park Royale et puis
nous avons
déménagé à euh rud
musi mais toujours dans le
mar et euh et puis en
1997 quand
Johnny Versace a été assassiné, je
ne me sentais pas du tout  sentant que je pouvais
retourner aux États-Unis, j'avais juste l'impression que
j'en avais besoin, je ne voulais pas y retourner, j'étais
tellement dévasté comme tout le
monde et j'ai donc trouvé un appartement
sur Rud
Ganell et euh, le numéro de ce 146
Rudo
Ganell  et mon voisin du dessus
était Alan
Donon, eh
bien, je l'ai déjà rencontré dans ce
restaurant ici à Paris appelé le
restaurant italien Straser et j'ai déjà rencontré son fils
Anthony mais
euh ouais j'ai adoré vivre là-bas, j'ai
adoré vivre à Paris et je veux dire Paris
a toujours été en France
et, en tant que nation complète, m'a toujours
beaucoup soutenu dans ma carrière, cela
m'a donné tellement de belles
opportunités, euh, de
pouvoir travailler avec euh Miss s
[Musique],
euh quand j'avais
17 ans, euh aaden Alia qui est mon papa Carl
Lagerfeld Jean Paul bien, ça a juste
été tu sais, tellement
incroyable j'ai beaucoup appris ici j'ai
beaucoup appris en vivant avec azadine j'ai
appris l'art j'ai appris l'
architecture j'ai rencontré ces
gens et ces musées les plus incroyables et et juste et
euh la littérature  et
les églises entrent dans ces belles
églises
pour la
cinquantaine à l'âge de seulement 16 ans, elle a
attiré l'attention des designers du
monde entier avec son
style frais et la sensibilité qui dépasse
son
âge, mais son aisance naturelle sur les podiums
a ses racines dans un  le simple plaisir sa
passion pour
la danse je vais à l'école des
arts du spectacle depuis l'âge de cinq ans et
je voulais être danseur ou acteur
et chanteur peu importe c'est ce que j'étais c'est ce que
je me forme depuis que je
suis  cinq pour le faire, pas
vraiment juste danser, je suppose que j'adore
danser, je pense que c'est un rêve devenu réalité, je
ne pensais pas que je serais assis ici maintenant
à faire ça, non, je le prends juste au jour le jour et ce qui
vient vient et ce qui ne se passe pas.  Je
ne vais pas manquer parce que je n'ai jamais
su que c'était le cas,
euh, je
pense que je pense que dans le premier spectacle d'aiia, c'est
définitivement le cas,
euh,
elle n'était pas ravie, vous savez, et c'est
compréhensible parce que, euh, j'étais allé dans
une école d'arts théâtraux.
ma euh toute ma vie donc elle m'a dit eh bien tu
sais, est-ce que tu vas gaspiller tout ce que
tu as appris
en gros euh
mais euh je n'ai pas l'impression de l'avoir gaspillé et
euh elle m'a finalement laissé entrer, laisse-moi le
faire
ou  donne-moi la permission de le faire, je
veux dire, je l'aurais fait de toute façon mais
c'est toujours agréable d'avoir la bénédiction de ta mère
je ne connaissais rien à l'
industrie de la mode rien du
tout absolument rien euh comme je l'ai
dit plusieurs fois je ne l'ai jamais je n'ai
jamais  j'ai acheté
des magazines de mode, euh, j'étais beaucoup plus intéressé
par la musique et les arts du théâtre à l'
époque
[Musique]
pour
Pap parce que cet homme avait l'énergie la plus incroyable
d'amour conditionnel inconditionnel
et le plus grand
talent
et il ne savait rien
à propos de moi et il m'a embrassé à une époque
où j'avais euh
eu 16 ans et vous savez, lui,
je n'avais aucune
idée de son talent jusqu'à ce que je
commence à vivre avec lui et à voir comment
il travaillait et à réaliser à quel point il était
unique et spécial mais juste  son énergie à elle
seule était tellement
attirante et je savais que j'étais en
sécurité, je savais que j'étais dans
des bras sûrs avec un papa en sécurité sous un
toit sûr et ma mère savait que j'étais en sécurité
et c'était une chose importante, tu sais, une
chose qu'elle  j'avais moins à m'inquiéter
et j'étais en
sécurité j'aimais mon
papa
je ne sais pas mais mademoiselle était un
homme tellement adorable pour moi et je l'ai rencontré
aussi je crois que j'avais
17 ans et ils m'ont embrassé dans la
cabine et j'ai aussi appris  tellement en
voyant la façon dont ils travaillaient la
différence j'ai appris la
différence entre le prêt Porte et la Couture et
les modèles Dalma imalia
cusia euh où trouves-tu ces
photos je ne sais jamais comment les trouver
je suis G pour les obtenir mais euh  non tout
comme la cabine Dalma et
imalia
katusa
munia euh ils étaient tous la lettre ils
aussi sur ton
manteau mon Dieu ils m'ont
embrassé et je leur demandais
quelle est la différence du prêt couture
et ils me l'ont montré
et comment  tu as enlevé la veste
comme tu le sais et c'est comme ça que j'ai
vraiment appris et j'ai beaucoup appris de
Mme S et j'ai des souvenirs si formidables et
merveilleux de
lui et de Lulu et de M.
B Madame
MOS
Nicole Cara ouais, c'était juste que ça allait dans un
autre monde  aller chez George
a coulé pour euh faire les essayages et une
discipline aussi parce que la discipline
était que tu ne pouvais pas simplement y aller en
jean et t-shirt devant
devant M. Sone non, tu devais être préparé
avant d'entrer  préparé la
préparation était les cheveux tirés en arrière dans
un rouge
à lèvres rouge brillant 10 collants darier satin noir
talons 3 et 1/2 et une fumée blanche alors
vous êtes prêt à être présenté à Mme,
elle fait partie de cette génération qui a
choisi le monde comme  le théâtre de son
opération et je suis vraiment très heureux que
nous ayons une jeune personne comme
elle euh pour se consacrer et pour faire
cela, nous appelons le succès c'est devenu je
t'aime vraiment merci
cette séquence particulière a été
réalisée sur  Le
14 février
1998, c'était un hommage à Johnny
Versace au profit du Fonds Nelson Mandela pour
l'enfance
et donc 78 personnes. J'ai demandé à 78 personnes,
maquillage compris et à tout le monde, de
me faire confiance et de s'envoler pour l'Afrique du Sud pour
cette
cause. C'était
grand-père
Tata que je l'ai appelé.  Tata, c'était Tata qui
accueillait tous ceux qui avaient volé de
tous les endroits différents pour que
cet événement se produise, donc c'était
vraiment
génial ouais, il a toujours dit que nous pouvions
dormir quand nous étions
partis,
euh, Tata m'a définitivement ouvert les yeux sur euh,
donner  en arrière de moi-même et en me faisant
réaliser que je pouvais utiliser qui j'étais et je
suis pour aider d'autres choses et faire d'autres
choses, il a définitivement apporté cette
prise de conscience dans mon esprit et ma vie
et j'ai commencé à travailler avec lui
à ses côtés et bien d'autres.  sur euh
à travers le Fonds Nelson Mandela pour l'enfance
mode
oui je le
ferai oh ouais celui-ci
merci beaucoup merci oui merci je vous remercierai oh oh c'est
fantastique oh c'est fantastique merci
beaucoupun art oh merci
c'est fantastique merci  c'est
sûr et est-ce qu'avec cette polaire juste
là,
voyons si c'est mignon ça pourrait être horrible
je ne peux pas faire une
droite
[Musique]
attends merci beaucoup merci je dois
laisser la polaire juste
là ok j'y vais  pour conclure
[Musique]
merci merci
au revoir merci beaucoup